الى عالم دراما ولمحبي الكوميديا
الاجتماعيه اعلنت منصه شاهد انطلاق الموسم
الثاني من مسلسل صالون زهره المسلسل الذي
حقق نجاحا في جزء الاول طرحت شاهد البرومو
تشويقي موعلينه ابتداء العرض اليوم العشره
نوفمبر طبعا المسلسل من بطوله
لبنان وسوريا والعمل من اخراج جوب وعيد
وتاليف الجزء الثاني بقلم كلوديا مرشالين
كشف البرومو الذي نشرته منصه شاهد نت
ومفاجات في قصه المسلسل منها مشاهد الاكشن
والتشويق والتي ستكون عاملا اضافيا
لمتابعته بجانب الكوميديا ورومانسيه
[موسيقى]
موس بقى يكفيها تظبيط شعر النسوان قلبت
على الرجال
[موسيقى]
ياي
حبيبي يقبرني شو اشتقت لك
[موسيقى]
دي شيلها الشفايف لي اياهم
من فريق شاهد يوسف اهلا بك انا بدي اولا
بسبب تصوير الجزء الثاني من صالون زهره
وبالنسبه للشاهد ما اهميه تصوير اجزاء
الثانيه من الاعمال الدراميه طبعا صالون
زهره انطلق اليوم باول حلقتين سبب الجزء
الثاني طبعا النجاح الكبير اللي لقاه
الجزء الاول كان ترينت لغايه
الجزء الثاني والجزء الثاني دخل الترين
بعرض اول حلقتين او حتى كمان من بدايه عرض
البرومو الخاص كثير بيهم شهد صراحه انها
تستمر بهاي الاعمال لانه هي هذه الاعمال
اللي بيحبها الجمهور الخفيفه اللطيفه
الكوميديه اللي قريبه منه وانت شكله كمان
عايش اجواء صالون زهره بما انه فتحوه فرع
للرجال
كنت من اوائل الناس اللي راحوا على همم
موسى شفره عشان زهره تهتم باطلاله اليوم
طبعا على هالسيره كيف كواليس العمل
والاجواء كانت كواليس صراحه جدا رائعه
شركه الانتاج وقعدنا نحكي اكثر عن كواليس
العمل قالوا لي اول شيء انت عم بتشوف غرفه
ومحبه كثير كبيره بالطاقه من العمل هلا في
كان شويه صعوبات لانهم ليه لانه في ايام
كانت شتاء وشفناها بالسوشال ميديا نزلتها
نادين انه كيف قادره يصوره تحت الشتاء كان
يجبرها الامبريلا كثير كبيره الشمسيه في
عندك همم من الاشياء كمان الصعبه كانت
عندهم بيكواليس العمل انه اغلب المشاهد
بين المحلات او بين الحواري يعني انت عم
بتشوفي مشاهد عم بتصير بين الشخصيات كثير
مش بس 1 يعني شخص اكثر
همم ساميه الجزائر الفنانه القديره نادين
نجيم وشوفنا البوست الخاص اللي نزلته
نادين نجيم على هذا الموضوع فاحنا عم نحكي
عن كواليس فاحنا كانت مليانه بالمحبه راح
نشوفها ماذا عن الناس كيف كانت ردود الفعل
ردود الافعال زي ما حكيت لكم كانت من
بدايه عرض انه صالون زهره راح يكون معانا
ان شاء الله بالجزء الثاني وهو تراند من
عرض اول حلقتين دخلت على السوشيال ميديا
هيك فضول الصبح عشان اشوف شروط الافعال
عندنا او على صفحه نادي لانها نزلت كلاب
بدي اجزم انه جميع ردود الافعال الايجابيه
يعني ما لقيت شيء انه سلبي او شيء
حضرت الحلقه اربعه خمس مرات من كثر ما انا
مبسوطه وحتى المشهد النهائي اللي شفناه
بنهايه الحلقه الاولى هذا من المشاهد هلا
صاير من الصبح
عدد حلقات قليله للمسلسل
هي كانت حلقه بس ولكن زهره طلبت انه
يكونوا حلقتين واحنا ما بنقدر نزعل زهره
فصارحلقتين اسبوعيا لمده خمس اسابيع ان
شاء الله طيب يوسف في تبقى معنا طبعا في
الاستوديو
من بيروت هالمره من السجن الى بيروت انضم
لنا المؤلفات
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك شكرا تواجدك معنا صباح
العربيه مبروك انطلاقه صالون زهره الجزء
الثاني
شكرا يسعد صباحكم طيب انت سلمتي الجزء
الثاني بعد النجاح الكبير الذي حققه الجزء
الاول لو نتحدث عن ابرز مخاوفك والتحديات
اللي كنت خايفه منها الجزء الثاني نجاح
الجزء الاول
اول شيء انا مثل ما قلت انا اخذت يعني على
عات جزء نص جزء الثاني من مسلسل كان كتير
نجح باول جزء مع الكذبه نادين جابر بوجه
لتحيه اييه انا اللي كان يعني مثل كانه
بتصدقي صعوبه كانت زيت لانه انا عم بعمل
جزء ثاني لمسلسل لانه على طول الجزء
الثاني بيكون في خوف بخصوص اذا الجزء
الاول نجح كثير بتكوني انت خايفه اول شيء
انك تنزلي
وكمان عم بتفكري شو بدك تعمل شيء جديد
لانه ابشع شيء بالجزء الثاني هو التكرار
كل ما رايناه بالجزء الاول يعني انا حاولت
اني اعمله اني اخذتها الكاركتورات كلها
حاولت اعمل منها كافيه حبكه ثانيه يعني
بالذات المصاري طبعا
واضفنا احداث جديده
بشويه ااا هيك مشاكل صارت معهن طبيعيه
تصير بالشارع اللبناني اليوم اللي نحنا عم
عايشين فيه كلوديا بالحديث عن فكره
التقليب انت بيكون في فكره براسك من خلال
السيناريو وطريقه الطرح هل الجميع بصراحه
نفذ فكره كلوديا مرشليان بالطريقه التي
تصورتها وتخيلاتها ام انك تحثرت على بعض
المقاطع
اللي هو عاده وخصوص اذا كان المسلسل
كوميدي وانا مش اول مره
ونحن معنا هون شخصيه اسمها زهره همم زهره
هي اصلا هذه فكره صالون زهره هي نادين همم
هي ارادت انه تعمل بالفكره من قبل ما يبلش
اول شيء هي بتحسيها انه هي مختارها
الشخصيه بتحسيها انه هي عم بتضيف عليها
باول جزء والثاني جزء كلمه حركه الاشياء
اللي بتعلق عليها يعني كاركتير زهره شربته
نادين لدارجه
في تفاصيل صغيره هي بتقول جمال صغير هي
بتقولها همم فيك بعض الكركترات كمان هيك
هيدا بالاتفاق بيني وبين المخرج وبين
الممثل بس مش معناتها انه بيتضرب بالاحداث
والتنضاره المسلسل
اللي يعني لما يكون معك كمان نجمات كبار
من سوريا ونجوم ونجمات من لبنان يعني اذا
واحد يعني طلب من المخرج انه هون يضيف
هالكلمه او هل التعبير هذا شيء انا ما ما
مفروض يضايق الكاتب ابدا بالعكس اللي
صاروا تركترات بيناتهم وصاروا عايشين من
جوه وطبيعه انه هيك يصير عندهم نهفاتهن
اللي على الارض يا اللي عم بيعملوها
تقريبا هن والمخرج يعني اما بما يختص
بالنص كنصه بالحوارات وبالمشاهد وبال-
بال- همم بالاحداث فطبعا هذه بتكون مكتوبه
بالنص من الاساس الاساسي تمام استاذه
كلوديا شو بدي احييك وبدي اسالك سؤال على
موضوع كتابه النصوص لبعض الفنانين مثلا
اضافه ساميه جزائري ووفاء وهدى اكيد كانت
اضافه جميله ولكن ساميه الجزائري طبعا
اشتهرت بدور ام محمود بالكوميديا واليوم
عم بنرجع بنشوفها بكوميديا مره اخرى قد
ايه كان يدك تحدي انك تطلعيها من قالب ام
محمود وندخلها بقالب ام انس
ست ساميه انا حضرتها بعد مرات هي طبعا ام
محمود هي الشخصيه الي برزت فيها وتقريبا
صار اسمها ام محمود اييه انا طلعت انا
عملت شخصيه بغض النظر يعني ما لها علاقه
باسم محمود كشخصيه ام محمود انا كتبته
لهالنجمه الكبيره اللي كنت الي الشرف اني
اكتب لها وانه هي تمثل دور انا كتبته هي
ست ساميه عندها همم عند همم يعني شخصيه
رائعه
ومهضومه كثير وعنده شيء من ام محمود يعني
بالنهايه حطت حاله
يعني حتى لما نشوفها بغير ادوار ما ضروره
تكون بيشبه دوري ام محمود يعني هون احنا
عندنا انا ما بتشبه محمود ابدا بالكرك بس
هي ست ساميه هي بتوصلنا
بطريقتها الخاصه مثل اي ممثل المهم
بالعالم كان على طول لما نحضره كوميديا عم
يعملها بيكون في وشويه وبيكون في التفاصيل
تبع الشخصيه اللي انت كاتبها انا ولا مره
فكرت بام محمود انا وعم بكتب لها فكرت بها
النجم الكبيره يا اللي اكيد راح تعمل شيء
من الدور وعملت طبعا ما النجمات الباقيين
كمان اللي معه احنا بنشكرك كثير على وجودك
معنا من بيروت المؤلفه كلوديا مرشليان
ويوسف زين الدين من فريق شاهد شكرا لك
شكرا لكم